does this look like a wedding photo
and/or I'm graduating whose Friday here
on its grace and it should normally be
fried Diaries however this week I had a
camera outage in that one camera I had
got lots in a purse one camera I had
doesn't have a battery charger and one
camera I had got borrowed to Hannah Hart
when she went to Vegas uh it's just me
and you don't get to see anything I did
this week it wasn't that great anyway
I'm going on my tumblr instead and ask
you guys what should we talk about today
and someone said April Fools pranks
April Fool's is next Tuesday it's April
1st whatever April 1st is so here are
some last-minute April Fools pranks that
I'm just gonna think of right now for
you when your friend or lover or enemy
of our family member is brushing their
teeth with the toothbrush as soon as
they get past one tooth just smack it
out of their hands and say that's a
toothbrush not a toothbrush you idiot
Craig's replace your friends hair wax
with a candle
it's made of wax pranked when your
friend asks you for corn on the cob just
give it to them crying to say I thought
you said corn on the SOB plate put
deodorant inside of their underwear cuz
that couch you stand prank take all
their socks out of the sock drawer and
then when they open the drawer to look
for them just be like let the Rose full
of socks
Pratt come home with the bouquet of
flowers and then when they accept them
say April flowers bring me showers and
then piss all over them price just put
broccoli in their ears when they sleep
pranked replace all their necklaces with
lace and then be like there's all your
necklaces hey wake them up by screaming
we're all gonna die someday
prank put some Parmesan cheese in their
body wash and just say it's the
Scrubbing Bubbles kind print :
Craigslist and hire a discus thrower to
come and stand over them while they
sleep and then when they wake up say
you've always wanted a discman when you
were younger pranked a lot of discus
throwers out there that need work if
they're like quietly watching TV just
take some salt and pepper and then come
up behind them and go like this tell
them you want to meet them for happy
hour at this new bar and give them an
address and then when they show up
you're gonna be having a staged funeral
for a stick of salami and they're gonna
be like what is this and you're gonna be
like it's a solemn meeting you've been
drugged
there's no liquor here it's dry I like
you Regina because I covered your
underwear and deodorant well there you
go there are a bunch of last-minute
April Fools pranks for you you're
welcome
I don't know you guys
spoiler alert but no not so spoiled that
hasn't reached the expiration date camp
Takota is now available for rent on
iTunes for $5 if you don't want to
purchase it but you can also purchase it
I rented that not gonna let forever